well as sally said we did see our first
90 degree day of 2021 and
everyone was really out and about
enjoying the warm weather this holiday
weekend
madison kimbrough spoke to los vegas
today who shared what it means to
finally
be out of the house and enjoying these
much-needed warmer days
what do you think of this weather today
it feels good it feels good to
play sports and be active spring is here
and across the valley a bunch of people
were outside
enjoying the first 90 degree day of the
year it's actually kind of beautiful
today bringing the kids out
not as much breeze i would say but it's
still nice
from picnics to playing on the jungle
gym to even playing ball
this afternoon the park was the place to
be a nice change as several people we
spoke to have already been vaccinated so
now they feel comfortable again
going out i'm taking this in i'm
enjoying this weather
and just basking in
not being in the house anymore it's
pretty much life-saving
to be able to get outside and around
people a little bit
on average the first 90-degree day in
las vegas occurs around
april 18th so we are about two weeks
ahead of schedule
it's nice we can play in the water we
can have
fun with kids and there's lots to do
tennis courts were also busy as playing
sports outside seemed to be a big
attraction today
las vegas joshua ibarra says he enjoys
these days because he knows what's to
come
you have to be able to enjoy this for as
long as it lasts
before it gets way too hot to be out
here with your kids